[Musik]
doch jetzt endlich mal auf du fettsack
oder echt politiker ich deine fresse mit
einem akkuschrauber
ich habe gelernt dass man gebe ich jetzt
einfach random kompletten völlig irgend
eine karte aus dem weg zum beispiel ist
einfach mal diese hier und ich sag dir
dass diese karte etwas über dich aus
sagt also ich ziehe jetzt unter von 321
[Musik]
krass oder das übrigens ihr mann im
eingangsbereich zum bild hängen habe das
jetzt allerdings ein bisschen gepumpt ja
das ist pure kommst sander übrigens
gestern abend in einer wolf gesagt also
ich würde mal vorschlagen dass du so um
ja doch so 11 uhr hier wäre ist ein ganz
andere einfach nur um halb zwei jahren
porto kicker dann um halb drei ist wie
ein foto geschickt wie sie am laufen ist
mit dem untertitel die begrüße ich hab
da noch mal geschrieben sandy morgen
uhrzeit steht und sie okay gab bis
morgen haben heute nacht einen typen
dreimal durch den hatten die spätest
gerade richtig
halb eins und drei mal dürft ihr raten
beachten dass mich wahrlich was man es
so gerade dass man die dass waldi der
computer ist ein neues schild hier ja
das ist ganz so peinlich
[Applaus]
er muss jetzt gerade eine kleine
spontane challenge verlegt und zwar hab
ich da vorne eine plastikflasche auf den
tisch gestellt und sandra hat die
rauschbrille auf und muss jetzt mit
dieser aus brille ihren ellbogen hinter
dem teppich mit dieser pistole dieses
ding abschießen und wäre es mit weniger
schwitzen schafft gewinnt
das war eine menge im vorstand soll die
lust und zeit haben eine lampe grad
getroffen
das macht es war auch ziemlich weiteren
hilfen und ich weiß jetzt dass auch der
kamera richtig rüberkommt weil die
kamera quasi nur ein auge hat aber guckt
euch das mal vergleicht das mal so ein
bisschen mit hier drunter und dann wenn
man das ding hat es ist so crazy zum
kind na ja bei dir wird ein kind glaube
ich habe ganz anders notizblock gefunden
und da steht einfach bock space
unterschiede einfach gar nichts warum
steht da nicht
[Musik]
ich habe ein video gesehen wo eine
person auf dem boden lag auf dem bau von
der anderen person hat sich für fünf
sekunden auf den rücken gestellt danach
wollte die person nicht mehr laufen
345 und jetzt stehe auf und gehe nach
vorne ganz nach vorne laufen die klappe
nicht ich zeig mir das siegtor videos
hochlud der box deswegen hat es nicht
funktionieren besuch von könnte die kein
anderer hersteller im babybecken
zusammen mit anderen ich habe meine
kopfhörer auf mit extrem da unsere
musiker versuchen jetzt eine
konversation zu hören eine rolex cloud
mein name ist gar nicht dahin aber das
wird eine rolex das ist meine kopfhörer
gehst jetzt schlafen
das sind bei der kopfhörer ich habe
morgen ein hund die leute sollen bei mir
dauert eben nicht bei dir das ist mein
gerät was mir bei meiner gekauft habe ja
kann ich gleich morgen machen aber jetzt
gerade muss sich das video aufnehmen ja
ich habe ordnung afrika zu hause
dann war mir das gerade extrem
langweilig deswegen hatten wir jetzt
gerade die idee dass wir noch eine
versteckte spiel in meiner wohnung 29 30
los geht's wenn ich weiß jetzt schon
ganz genau wo die s
[Musik]
hier in der schweiz nicht direkt wo der
lukas ist wenn er zeige ich euch jetzt
ok ja der ausleger auf erst
hundertprozentig darauf eine getränke
sind okay fragt mich fragt gefragt aber
mich an grad meist auf video aufgenommen
waren deuten auf tik tok es ist halt so
die brauchen dann in die fünf bis zehn
sekunden für sein video bei uns ich
brauche jetzt erst mal eine stunde auf
ein bisschen zerstreut und befinde mich
momentan in gemischten teams anderer
selber das war die das schon nicht mehr
kaufen als weg ist es mittlerweile
dunkel raus und ich habe gerade die
ganze zeit noch youtube videos
geschnitten und immer wenn ich videos
schneiden stelle ich mir so komische
fragen und die frage die ich mir gerade
gestellt habe ist warum ist atem
also warum ist das warm und wenn man
pustet also warum ist das kalt
ist die antwort der stelle ist heute in
block 2 ist auch wieder vorbei meine
lieben freunde wenn es euch gefallen hat
er das gerne einen daumen hoch unter dem
video dann genauso wie beim letzten
wochen richtig auf den heutigen block
wieder mit einem witz beenden warum
trinken veganer kein leitungswasser weil
es aus dem hahn kommt
[Musik]